l'ex culture deux mineurs marocains
entrés illégalement en espagne pourra se
poursuivre c'est le nouvel épisode des
tensions entre le maroc et l'espagne sur
fond de crise migratoire et précision de
leslie singh l'a
alors qu'une trêve de 72 heures était
annoncé le haut tribunal de l'audience
nationale a refusé de suspendre
l'expulsion de neuf mineurs marocains
vers leur pays d'origine les
rapatriements de mineurs vers le maroc
pourront donc se poursuivre malgré le
fait que la loi espagnole sur
l'immigration était invoquée pour
bloquer ce retour il faut le rappeler
qu'en mai dernier entre 8000 et 10000
personnes sont arrivées illégalement à
ceuta depuis le territoire marocain tout
est parti de brahim ghali leader de
front polisario qui réclame
l'indépendance du sahara occidental et
s'oppose au pouvoir de rabat son accueil
en espagne pourraient être soignés en
avril dernier avait été l'étincelle
d'une crise majeure entre l'espagne et
le maroc le royaume chérifien avait donc
décidé de relâcher sa vigilance à la
frontière et de nombreux migrants on
avait profité aujourd'hui il y aurait
700 mineurs a renvoyée vers le maroc
selon les autorités espagnoles le
rapatriement avait débuté il ya quelques
jours mais le tribunal l'a suspendu
quelques heures à la suite d'un recours
déposé par une ong les associations de
soutien aux migrants considère que ce
dispositif viole la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant à
laquelle adhèrent l'espagne un traité
qui exige que l'enfant soit écouté lors
de toute procédure judiciaire ou
administrative le ministère de
l'intérieur espagnol se décharge de
toute responsabilité en visant les
autorités de ceuta mais il défend cette
décision en expliquant que les enfants
sont renvoyés avec le consentement du
pouvoir marocain